Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute machen wir Kibbeh bil Laban, das ist ein unfassbar leckeres Gericht aber es braucht ein bisschen Vorbereitung
und es ist ein bisschen mühsam, das vorzubereiten.
Ich möchte euch jetzt aber nicht von Anfang an abturnen, das nachzumachen,
sondern das ist eins dieser Gerichte, bei dem man am Ende sagt: "Boah, jeder Bissen ist ein Genuss!"
Wir fangen an mit dem Teigmantel, der besteht bei diesem Gericht aus
einer Mischung aus Bulgur und Fleisch und innen drin ist auch nochmal Hackfleisch.
Zeige ich euch gleich aber alles in aller Ruhe.
Ich habe euch nämlich vorher abstimmen lassen für mein Kochbuch, das ja jetzt ganz, ganz neu rauskommt:
Wollt ihr im Kochbuch lieber Içli Köfte (das ist nämlich die türkische Variante)
oder Kibbeh bil Laban (das ist die arabische Variante)?
Und da im Buch die türkische Variante drin ist, habe ich mir gedacht, zeige ich euch die Arabische.
Also ich schnacke gar nicht mehr lange drumherum und gebe direkt meinen feinen Bulgur
in eine ausreichend große Schüssel. Da gebe ich jetzt auch schon mein warmes bzw. heißes Wasser hinzu,
verrühre das ganz kurz und lasse es dann zugedeckt mindestens 20min aber noch besser 30min stehen.
Während der Bulgur jetzt schön ziehen kann, kümmern wir uns um unser Fleisch und um unsere Zwiebeln.
Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen übrigens wie immer unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Für dieses Rezept ist es super, super wichtig, dass ihr mageres Rindfleisch verwendet.
Es muss komplett - also da darf gar kein Fett dran sein.
Das könnt ihr beim Metzger auch so durchgeben bzw. sagt dem Metzger auch direkt
oder fragt ihn, ob er das für euch 3-4x durchwolfen kann, das wäre nämlich der Idealfall.
Ich habe hier jetzt ganz normales mageres Rindfleisch und werde das jetzt hier in meinen Mixer geben
zusammen mit den Zwiebeln, denn wir brauchen wirklich eine Art Püree,
also das ist super wichtig für den äußeren Teigmantel.
So, Hackfleisch und Zwiebeln sind vorbereitet und falls ihr z.B. jetzt keinen Mixer habt,
versucht's gern auch mit 'nem Pürierstab.
Das habe ich grad auch mal versucht um zu sehen, ob's klappt und das funktioniert auch wunderbar.
So, und als nächstes nehmen wir uns jetzt unseren Bulgur, der jetzt schön lange ruhen konnte.
Und ich brauche noch immer wieder Ruhzeiten, daher sage ich ja: Leute, ihr braucht echt Geduld!
Und gerade am Ramadan ist es so: man hat eh so den ganzen Tag auch Zeit,
sich ausgiebig dann ums Kochen zu kümmern, sage ich mal.
Und da kann man sich ja z.B. mit der Mutter oder der Schwester zusammensetzen und das Ganze machen.
[Hamza] Ich finde aber aufwendige Rezepte müssen auch mal sein. Also nicht immer nur schnell und einfach, sondern auch mal..
[Kiki] Gerne auch mal was Aufwendiges, das mag ich nämlich auch!
So, und hier gebe ich jetzt Hackfleisch und Zwiebeln zur Bulgurmasse
und außerdem noch Gewürze.
Ich liste euch zwar sowieso alles unten in der Videobeschreibung auf,
aber zu den Gewürzen neben Salz und Pfeffer kommt hier noch
Zimt, Kreuzkümmel, Paprikapulver und 7-Gewürzmischung mit rein.
Die 7-Gewürzmischung, die gibt's natürlich auch bei mir im Shop, die verlinke ich euch
und das ist so eine typisch arabische Gewürzmischung und die ist eigentlich unverzichtbar in diesem Rezept.
[Hamza] Also ein Allrounder!
[Kiki] Ein Allrounder, genau.
Ich habe die Mischung jetzt hier ungefähr schon 10min geknetet und man muss noch viel, viel mehr kneten
aber an der Stelle fange ich schonmal an, noch mehr Wasser mit dazu zu geben.
Diesmal nicht kochendes damit ich mir einfach die Finger nicht verbrenne
sondern richtig schön warmes. Und das gebe ich auch nur schlückchenweise mit dazu.
Ihr bekommt dann ein Gefühl dafür, wann das fertig ist und das zeige ich euch im Anschluss auch.
Aber nachdem ich jetzt noch weitere 5min geknetet habe, gebe ich's nochmal zugedeckt
zur Seite, allerdings diesmal in den Kühlschrank für weitere 20min
und dann zeige ich euch gleich, wie wir die Füllung machen.
So, während jetzt der Teig im Kühlschrank ausruht,
hab ich mir gedacht machen wir schonmal die Füllung. Die geht auch super, super easy.
Dafür habe ich hier meine beschichtete Pfanne, gebe da neutrales Öl und Butter Ghee rein.
Butter Ghee gibt einfach nochmal diesen klassischen Geschmack
und wenn ihr das jetzt nicht da habt, könnt ihr das auch durch Öl ersetzen aber
vertraut mir, versucht's mal mit!
Und da werde ich jetzt die Pinienkerne fast schon frittieren, würde ich sagen,
also sie sollen eine schön goldbraune Farbe annehmen.
Und direkt im Anschluss Hackfleisch und fein gehackte Zwiebeln mit dazu geben.
So, hier sind auch schon die ganzen Gewürze mit rein gekommen,
dann habe ich das nur noch 2min lang auf mittelhoher Hitze dünsten lassen
und die Füllung ist auch schon fertig.
Summa summarum 10min für die Füllung, mehr braucht ihr dafür nicht.
Ich widme mich jetzt aber wieder dem Teig, den habe ich nämlich gerade aus dem Kühlschrank genommen
und der hat jetzt wirklich nochmal gut durchziehen können.
Ihr könnt auch jetzt nochmal kneten und nach und nach
schlückchenweise Wasser dazugeben.
Der Teig ist schon relativ klebrig würde ich sagen.
Also wenn ihr den so in die Hand nehmt, dann bleibt er aber auch zusammen, das ist super wichtig.
Und so wird das jetzt nicht funktionieren mit trockenen Händen,
ihr müsst euch die mit Wasser immer mal wieder befeuchten, das ist super wichtig.
Und jetzt nehmt ihr euch einfach ein bisschen Teig und es geht jetzt einfach darum,
dort quasi einen dünnen Rand zu bilden
und eine Mulde drin zu bilden damit die Füllung Platz hat.
Und da quatsche ich gar nicht viel, sondern zeige es euch lieber per Video,
so ist es nämlich viel einfacher.
Und dann kannst du Hamza einfach mal näher rankommen und ein bisschen filmen.
Die typische Form ist quasi so eine Zitronenform.
Also nach hinten hin schön spitz formen mit den 2 Fingern
und dann könnt ihr das Ganze umdrehen und die andere Seite auch nochmal spitz formen.
So, ich habe jetzt schonmal eine handvoll vorgeformt und werde sie jetzt auch schon frittieren.
Ich habe hier ganz normales Frittierfett genommen in meiner Hochrandpfanne
und ihr merkt, dass das Fett soweit ist wenn auf einem Holzstäbchen -
da könnt ihr auch z.B. einen Schaschlikspieß nehmen - wenn da Bläschen aufsteigen.
Sie steigen hier fast schon ein bisschen zu schnell auf. Sie müssen jetzt nicht so schnell aufsteigen,
deswegen gehe ich jetzt nochmal runter mit der Hitze und generell müsst ihr euch vorstellen -
da machen auch immer viele den Fehler - ihr gebt ja die Kibbeh ins heiße Fett.
Aber die sind ja an sich nicht heiß. Das heißt das Fett nimmt dann auch nochmal eine andere Temperatur an
nach dem ersten Frittiervorgang. Dann könnt ihr hier mit der Hitze immer wieder hoch und runter gehen,
also reguliert das immer schön selbst, das ist super wichtig.
Und jetzt gebe ich die einfach rein und dann brauchen die ungefähr 2½-3min, je nach Größe.
Und dann sind sie auch schon fast fertig, dann kommt nämlich nur noch die leckere Joghurtsoße.
[Kiki] Und jetzt frittiert das nicht! Warum? Man merkt, dass das Fett jetzt eine andere Temperatur hat.
[Hamza] Gerade ging das viel schneller.
[Kiki] Ja.
[Hamza] Das stimmt. Du bist echt schlau, Kiki!
So, die Kibbeh sind jetzt vollständig frittiert, die brauchen wir gleich wieder.
Jetzt kommt unsere leckere Joghurtsoße.
Es mag vielleicht befremdlich rüberkommen, Joghurt zu erwärmen
aber vertraut mir: Das ist so, so lecker!
Ich habe jetzt hier Joghurt - kleinen Augenblick - und einen Teigschaber
und gebe den in meinen Topf, der Herd ist noch aus.
Noch nicht einschalten!
So, da habe ich jetzt schon Wasser reingegeben. Als nächstes Salz und Minze
wobei die Minze eher optional ist. Ich persönlich finde, dass die richtig gut passt.
Und zur Bindung Speisestärke und ein Ei.
Und jetzt ist es super wichtig, dass ihr die ganze Zeit rührt, ihr düft nicht aufhören!
Das Ganze dauert jetzt auch 10-15min
und ich schalte dann auch gleich schonmal den Herd ein auf die mittlere Stufe
und rühre und rühre und rühre. Vielleicht kannst du mir ja zwischendurch mal helfen, Hamza!
[Hamza] Ja, ich nehme alles auf!
So, ich habe jetzt 15min lang richtig schön gerührt, das durfte dann 15min lang köcheln
und die Konsistenz ist schon ein bisschen dickflüssiger geworden.
Und als nächstes könnt ihr schon eure Kibbeh mit reingeben in den warmen Joghurt
aber es kommt noch ein leckeres Topping und dann sind wir auch fertig mit dem Rezept.
Ich glaube ich gebe aber zuallererst die Kibbeh rein und zeige euch dann, was wir fürs Topping machen.
Ich habe jetzt Olivenöl erwärmt, allerdings nur auf mittlerer Stufe,
denn Olivenöl darf nicht allzu sehr erhitzt werden.
Und da habe ich dann noch Knoblauch und Petersilie mit rein gegeben.
Das Ganze nur 1-2min lang dünsten und fertig.
Was ich auch zuvor erledigt habe, ist einmal Pinienkerne anzurösten
weil die passen natürlich perfekt nochmal on top weil sie auch innen drin sind.
Ich nehme mir jetzt einen hübschen Teller
und gebe da jetzt erstmal von meinen Kibbeh mit Joghurtsoße rein
und dann gebe ich das Topping oben drauf, die Pinienkerne on top
und dann das Ganze schön warm genießen.
Ihr könnt übrigens Kibbeh auch einfrieren, dafür einfach die fertigen Kibbeh in das Gefrierfach legen
für ungefähr 10-15min, dann werden sie schön hart
und dann könnt ihr sie in einer gefriergeeigneten Frischhaltedose verpacken
oder eben in einem Gefrierbeutel, das ist auch kein Problem.
So, ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Schaut auf jeden Fall unten in die Videobeschreibung für die ganz genauen Mengenangaben
und folgt mit unbedingt auf Instagram, denn dort könnt ihr den #ramadanmitkiki benutzen
wenn ihr z.B. etwas von mir nachmacht
und auch in diesem Hashtag sehen, was andere aus der Kikimunity machen.
Ich folge diesem Hashtag nämlich auch
und freue mich dann, wenn ihr alle fleißig kocht und backt nach meinen Rezepten.
Und ansonsten: Habt noch wunderschöne Tage und bis zu meinem nächsten Video!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!